[Music]
one of the best things about being a
voice actor is that you don't have to be
attractive to land a leading role in
Hollywood but just because some actors
voice Dorothy characters does that mean
they are also working in real life if
you are a first-time viewer click the
red subscribe button and prepare to be
shocked because today we are exposing
ten awkward cartoon characters voice
play attractive actors Eliza Thornberry
The Wild Thornberrys Eliza Thornberry is
an 11 year old girl who has more of a
tomboy attitude her nerdy character is
even more accentuated by her glasses
graces and ability to speak to animals
but it may surprise you to learn that
the girl who voiced Eliza Thornberry is
a far cry from the office Queen cartoons
prepare to be shocked because the lazy
Shaver who you may recognize as directed
wieners for screen girls is actually the
voice behind Eliza Thornberry max do a
goofy movie in business a goofy movie we
see the life of max Keith and his
struggle to be relevant in high school
his struggle is even more real because
duty is his father
but just because max is a bit goofy on
screen it doesn't mean the actors in
voices image Jason Larson not only voice
next - but he was also a teen heartthrob
in the 90s looking at him now not much
has changed because he's still easy on
the eyes as opposed to Flora max cube
Meg Griffin Family Guy when it comes to
being an aqua teen Meg Griffin from
Family Guy has it all
her family constantly forgets her and
nearly everyone is your school wants
nothing to do with our not and real life
everyone adores the actress who brings
Mexican
characters like super-hottie Mila Kunis
has voiced Meg Griffin since the second
season of the series
too bad Meg only has Milla's voice
because the middle child of the Griffin
family would probably be more beloved if
she has his good looks as well anna
frozen speed cuts the awkward and
constantly bubbling the fat doesn't keep
the audience from loving honor and
Disney's hit movie frozen she has the
nerdy appeal of someone who is easygoing
and approachable but to the contrary the
actress who plays her would stop anyone
in their tracks with her beauty the
adorable actress Kristen Bell lends her
voice to the fumbling character and in
real life she is anything but awkward
Bobby hill king of the hill he isn't
talented at sport nor to see haggis down
with the ladies but Bobby hill from king
of the hills and I have a heart the
Queen also didn't get too lucky in the
looks department but you will be
surprised to learn who did it's already
surprising that a woman voices Bobby
hill but the fact that it's a hot woman
is even more shocking
Pamela Alden voiced the sweet late
bloomer for 13 seasons which means he
will probably never watch the cartoon
the same way again Sam sparks Cloudy
with a Chance of Meatballs the movie
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs
features Sam sparks a fast-talking
overly excited weather intern in the
film she admits that he was once a nerd
girl which isn't hard to believe but the
fact that adorable comedic actress Anna
Faris voices Sam sparks is a bit hard to
comprehend no Anna does are cute nerdy
moments in real life she can hardly be
described as an awkward wide-eyed intern
Sally brown peanut in the Peanuts comic
strip and movies all Sally Brown wanted
in life was to be loved by Linus sadly
it was a one-way road but something you
may not know is that one of the most
famous seniors actually voiced
Sally Browns character when he was just
9 years old
Stacy Ferguson clean may know as Fergie
was the voice of the lovesick Sally
brown which is crazy because we are sure
Fergie could have any guy she wants
Cardon check the third I'm sorry dings
ominous try introduce everyone to the
nerdy Prince to be arty things were so
bad for him in high school
even the
mentioning dorks thought he was a geek
but the voice behind the character is
one of the most charming men in the
world that's right
granny Artie from Shrek the third is
voiced by the hunky finger Justin
Timberlake considering his smoothness on
the stage it's hard to imagine Kimberlin
ever had an awkward teen phase timmy
turner
The Fairly OddParents timmy turner from
The Fairly OddParents is known for his
buck teeth and ability to have whatever
he wants thanks Gary godparents one of
the things we desperately want is to
move up the social ladder at a school
sadly it never quite works out but when
you lift the veil and see two points is
the control boy it's shocking Paris
strong who voices timmy is a gorgeous
blonde woman and we aren't even sure how
she relates to Verner decreasing
character ribbit troll if you see the
movie troll
you may notice tweet and energy prison
also known as Lady glitter crinkles
before lovesick Bridget wants to win the
heart of the king but she is the most
beautiful Bergen in the made-up world
the sweet Bergen is voiced by none other
than famous new girl actress Zooey
Deschanel
thanks to death-knell courage it has the
voice of an angel
despite her scullery-maid outer
appearance were you surprised by these
voices behind awkward cartoon characters
react in the comment section below and
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to the same
[Music]